in this challenge episode we're gonna
play on the craziest table sets up cover
a table full of ping pong balls and more
we have to play doubles without losing
the ball so how do you remove like we
have to like we move like this yeah you
got it yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
well we can do like this
oh yeah I have a feeling something's
going to happen there's so many
different styles available for this
[Music]
yeah
okay
you look like a crap what's left no
shots against this combo deadly
that's the game
we made him laugh and I was the goal of
the challenge we gotta go hard
I think that's enough next challenge
this is the amount of balls you need to
cover a whole table start by just
covering the whole surface with tape I
don't think I've ever seen a yellow ping
pong table you are ready with the balls
because you wanna heal world's stickiest
table
it
sticks without pressing it's
surprisingly satisfying to place the
balls like in the correct place there
wouldn't you agree that this is one
ballsy move from pumpkin
final ball of the puzzle whoa that took
like one hour to complete this table
Yeah I just made the calculations
2859 balls
after the video each and every order
from pongfinity dot store will come with
one of these balls and it will be signed
by all three of us we have to do an air
MIL stand test no don't do the animals
try I'll try
all right so let's play on the table
covered with balls
it's not promising I think this is a
game where it's based purely on Lux 90
luck
supposedly you're not allowed to use
this surface okay
unpredictable I have to say if you're
playing on this for a few times a week I
think you'll never miss an edge ball
this is the way get the cleanest bounce
snake crazy side spin
[Music]
good training reflex training and like
rockets handling skills next up we will
have
any balls on a table with many balls
easy
that is perfect you can get it I want to
say
change
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
[Music]
that is fun and guys if you want to get
yourself an own piece of this table go
ahead and order anything from pumpkin
store and you will get one of these
balls signed by all three of us
one of our wildest table setups the goal
is five
I have a feeling tree slots is quite the
maximum we can get let's try it out
very difficult one
[Applause]
it looks so like weird and impressive no
life as long as we get the touch for the
no
if it comes here you just have to put
more side Spin and then it corrects it
no for me it's almost this
oh
zero one zero
that's perfect if it doesn't come like
out of the table so much
[Applause]
that's crazy that you can actually play
on something that's sideways comical to
think
[Music]
I think we smashed that next challenge
guess the heater
[Music]
Michael yes
I'm not gonna give you any Mercy after
that
[Applause]
come I felt the revenge
[Music]
how
yeah guys
we have five serves and the one who gets
most points wins and they're going to be
very illegal so the first serve
foreign
[Music]
I'm running out of ideas
oh you got a point
oh it didn't work
first one to get the last piece of the
puzzle
that's good that's good that's good
this is quite a bit harder than I
expected
I can just put it like this and that's
equally yeah
oh
I mean this might take two hours this
might take two days
six hours we shoot at the same time
come on just somebody get it in now okay
if you really want
[Applause]
[Music]
it
we just have to find the right technique
yeah and everybody together every single
order within the next month will get a
ball from this table signed by all three
of us so go ahead and make your order
now